well
the metropolitan police are
looking for a suspect in connection with
a shooting inside an apartment complex
in the center of the city
that is hi cristian cásseres
this happened on sunday at noon
inside an apartment near
wyoming and las vegas back  the subject
shot two people one of them
died and another is seriously injured
authorities believe the suspect
knew the victims
the two defendants in two fatal shootings
face new charges including
murder that had lamb and york in
rugby face charges of intent  of
robbery with the use of a deadly weapon for the
shooting in the mouse seat and in the
palace station the police inform that
both tried to rob their victims
before starting the shootings a
66-year-old woman died in the altercation
sales in showmatch while  a
man in his 50s and a 50-year-old died
during the events at the station an
expert that the technology convention
c  Known as yes, he announced that he will still hold
his conference in person but
culminating one day earlier than normal,
the conference will be from Wednesday to
Friday, with the purpose of protecting the
health and safety of attendees, they
must verify that they are vaccinated
against Betis and 9, in addition to using  the face
mask and we close with the
temperatures for the first week of
the new year as we can see we will
have a sunny sky with some
clouds in bayern we will be at 50
degrees for the highs and 30 degrees
for the lows I am Cristian Cásseres
with your new information on  news now
spanish good day and happy new year